[Music]
are you sure about this sir no major i'm
not
this son of a [ __ ] is our only hope
he's what we like to call a problem
inmate why's that he doesn't
[Applause]
why me you were specifically requested
mac i'm not going to sugarcoat it it's a
suicide mission
who let the dog out
my country has invited me to die for it
and i are svp gas queen
[Applause]
uncle sam tells you to jump and you go
get your jumping ships classic mcgregor
hello magruber
this isn't just any mission for me this
is personal he murdered my mother
i'm men thank you soldier you're gonna
get us all killed
millions of people are gonna die we're
talking about a world in here i think
it's time to call the calvary we are the
[ __ ] cavalry
time to go make some widows get shot
smell you later vic i mean that with
every fiber of my pain
i will smell you later
mcgrover
i think it might be time for a little r
and r uh yes i could use some rest and
relaxation oh
the other r r
ramming and [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you